[Music]
the 2016 US presidential election is not
the first time the Russians have tried
to influence Western democratic
processes we are going to keep our
country safe at all times in my
experience and knowledge we the Soviets
always tried to influence the elections
Oleg Kalugin was a Soviet spy stationed
in the United States in the late 50s he
joined the KGB the Soviet Union Secret
Service in 1952 a year before Stalin's
death he rose quickly through the ranks
becoming the KGB's youngest general at
the age of 38 in 1975 the KGB got a new
repeatable Russia's future President
Vladimir Putin Putin proved to be an
effective manager because of his
vigorous businesslike approach the only
foreign assignment Putin ever had was
East Germany while Putin was a low
ranking KGB officer mr. Kalugin was one
of the top Soviet spies my main job in
the KGB was a recruitment of human
sources foreign sources
I was quite successful I recruited
several people they provided me with
classified information all of them were
Americans when Mikhail Gorbachev became
the General Secretary of the Communist
Party in 1985 and launched perestroika
the political movement for Reformation
in the party Kalugin joined the camp of
the Reformers and spoke out against the
KGB I was transferred to st. Petersburg
and for the first time I learned truth
about my own country
to work against your own people now it
was the people of Russia who wanted to
change
I wanted the reforms and my job was to
gag them up silenced them open jail
my knowledge of my own country under the
Soviet system made me a different man
Kalugin was removed from the KGB and
sought political immunity in the Soviet
Parliament later he claimed political
asylum in America where he lives today
he is now a prominent critic of the
Soviet system and his former KGB
subordinate Vladimir Putin it so
happened that mr. Putin my former
subordinates came to power and publicly
denounced me as a traitor
well I publicly called him a war
criminal or the war in Chechnya Putin as
a leader he is smart he is sly his
central theory it is alleged that a
Kremlin linked group interfered with a
2016 US election to damage the prospects
of Democratic candidate Hillary Clinton
13 Russians and three Russian
organizations have been indicted as part
of an investigation into Russian
election interference
President Putin denies any involvement
by the Kremlin in this case I believe
the Russian hackers former not just
individuals doing things on their own
they were motivated or directed by their
bosses in Moscow when the Soviet Union
collapsed in 1991 russia's first
president Boris Yeltsin divided the KGB
and renamed it but he didn't close it
down
the KGB now known as the FSB has even
more political power than it had under
the communist party in the Soviet era
today the FSB is running the country and
the president of the country is a former
KGB officer many say Putin's 15 years in
the KGB has characterized his leadership
and the Russian state Putin is not a
dictator of the old days he's a far more
sophisticated man he knows how to
manipulate people if someone really is
not careful enough may be removed
through polonium or something else
the KGB might have been renamed but its
modus operandi remains the same the
heart of the Russian security services
at all times was control of people's
minds and hearts keeping them obedient
servants of the state the techniques of
Russia's intelligence services have
changed since Kalugin time when human
sources were key today modern techniques
like hacking patrolling and fake online
accounts are the weapon of choice one
thing is certain the KGB was removed in
nothing but name and is still firmly at
the heart of the Russian state
you